buildings are surprisingly big in their
impacts all buildings generally
contribute to climate change it turns
out that buildings are responsible for
about 40 percent of the carbon emissions
Living Building Challenge shines a light
on what needs to change
I grew up in northern Canada in a mining
city called Sudbury and Sudbury was
famous for its environmental pollution
we had at the time the world's tallest
smokestack was taller than the Eiffel
Tower and looked like a big cigarette
stuck in the ground and when I was very
little I used to think it was a cloud
making machine until my mother corrected
me that it was a pollution and
cancer-causing machine and that also
inspired me to be an environmentalist at
a young age I became frustrated with I
would call the rate of change in the
building industry I think you know
somewhere in you know 2004-2005 I really
decided that I needed to create a new
framework for the building industry and
began working on it so when somebody
came to our Foundation and asked for a
grant to pursue the Living Building
Challenge as a way of influencing
architecture we not only made them a
grant that we started to investigate
whether we could build a building
ourselves the bullet foundation is is at
its core and environmental philanthropy
and I I genuinely believe that people
who work in a field need to walk their
talk Living Building Challenge is saying
how do we build with materials that are
more responsible how do we not
contribute to climate change it's a very
different way of looking at the role
that buildings play in the environment
we started looking at the office space
that's available in Seattle the building
that we were in was wildly inefficient
and I just felt we needed to move to
someplace that was greener we decided we
would go and build our own building and
explore kind of the frontiers of what
could be done
we set out to build a really super high
performance building and when we did
that we had one main goal in mind and
that was to meet the Living Building
Challenge to be net zero energy net zero
water to make a building that does no
harm to people or the planet so net zero
energy is an interesting concept what it
means is that on an annual basis the
building uses as much electricity as it
generates so we are looking at renewable
sources of energy
and that led us to wind and solar wind
is not an ideal solution in an urban
setting where you have a lot of
buildings and a lot of turbulence solar
was really going to be the ideal
solution and and of course this is
Seattle so we weren't sure how it was
gonna work it was understandable that
there was skepticism when we look at the
average commercial office building in
Seattle they have an energy use index of
something like 72 Killah BTUs per square
foot per year the target for this
building at the end of simulation was 16
a lot of folks justifiably said you know
you can't do that so the main approach
to that is actually by not using lots of
energy in the first place most of the
building is designed around working with
the climate using the Sun using the wind
using the light to create a comfortable
environment and the building is
activated by the weather so when a cloud
goes over the shades go up when the Sun
comes out they go down and in the
building enclosure is almost alive the
biggest challenge with hitting the net
zero energy target was that we couldn't
control what the tenants do if people
within the office choose to bring in a
high energy consumption equipment such
as space heaters it really jeopardizes
meeting their energy budget so there's a
strong incentive to use energy in a
smart way in the end we produced 54
percent more energy than we used last
year the building and its tenants prove
the skeptics wrong with water in the
Living Building Challenge we talked
about being net positive the building
uses rain water for all purposes our
systems are in place to capture
rainwater on the roof when the rain
falls it goes down into a cistern in the
basement of the building and then water
is pulled through a series of filters to
remove any impurities and we're left
with clean potable water the building
actually captures a lot more rainwater
it needs and so you know it's an
opportunity to actually supply other
other buildings with rain water so it's
almost a little municipal water
treatment plant right in the middle of
the city there's something called sick
building syndrome and a lot of office
buildings especially in downtown
locations there
the windows don't open the indoor air
quality can actually be really terrible
and bad for human health and it's
because so many of the materials inside
the building are putting off toxic fumes
productivity has gone up for the people
that move into the building and for sure
Health has theirs let's sick leave here
and finally that a surprise to everyone
people who have seasonal affective
disorder in Seattle people who get
depressed by the near constant cloud
cover see that tend to go away when
they're in the bullet center they're
exposed to so much natural light that
they just don't get that depression
well at the time that the bullet center
was being done it was the biggest living
building here we had we were pushing the
boundaries with the solar array we're
pushing boundaries with the water system
and so there were a lot of hurdles that
we had to get through and those are
things we were we were concerned about
five years ago if you had said we're
gonna have an office building in Seattle
powered entirely by the Sun people might
have thought what are you talking about
can't be done it's Seattle it's cloudy
but we've done it and now we've shown
people that it's possible and I suspect
it within five or ten years we're gonna
see a lot of buildings that are better
than the Bullitt Center in terms of
their use of energy and their beauty and
their ability to provide healthy
environments without leaving an
environmental impact we've toured maybe
eight thousand people through this
building since its opened and that
includes lots and lots of people who
have been inspired by the building and
want to follow this path I hope to
change a lot of things with the creation
of the Living Building Challenge I I
wanted to just shake the building
industry up to challenge them that's why
the word challenge is in the title to
think very differently I want to see new
products that are healthier out in in
the industry I want to see better
buildings that are more energy efficient
water efficient and we've had a lot of
success which is very exciting
you
[Music]